just like to remember everybody that at
the end of the day we have some time for
discussion so the idea is that um like
more specific questions or that are
taking too much we can move to this end
of the day also you know the idea of the
work to have this calization of ideas
from different topics it would be nice
also if we can get together people
commun to
talk
okay and with that I welcome our first
Speaker good morning everyone you hear
me I think I hear
myself um my plan today is to talk about
end all search spaces and how are we
they are being used for Anytime
algorithms as the center of any times
algorithms for probabilistic reasoning
and uh here I have a my collaborators
how do I Point well I just you see them
so these are just a sublist of
collaborators in recent years this is
work that is ongoing for almost 20 years
and I will just give sort of an overview
of uh the work that is related to end or
search spaces so this is my plan uh I
will start by uh commenting about the
relationships between and orar spaces
and arithmetic circuits talk give a
small overview of and our search spaces
and touch about compilation and our
multivalue decision
diagrams and how we are using rather
than doing compilation we are using this
as uh the basis of
solving uh a problems in a timely
fashion not exactly
approximately and then if we have time I
will talk about our recent work on
abstraction sampling and the rest of the
work so let me start here is an example
of a very simple uh basing Network at
the top and on the left you see an end o
search Tre that that captures the same
uh probability distribution that the Bas
network is capturing and on the right
you have the arithmetic circuit you can
see the structure is very similar
syntactically the only the main
difference is that in arithmetic
circuits the parameters are at the lies
and in Endor search graphs like in
decision trees also they are on the
arcs in more details if we want to look
at them side by side so basically they
are isomorphic under some some condition
over arithmetic circuits you can move
from one to the other especially if the
starting point is the Bas and network or
the
graphic they uh you have sudores that
guide Endo surg trees as I will describe
the trees are used for arithmetic
circuits uh but the main focus that I
already articulated is how do we use
them so population is the main focus of
the Artic circuit community and anytime
ystic search algorithm is the the other
Focus that I will disc today the input
is also sometimes different if you can
start from a full graphical models and
then move to one on to this
representation
or you can start from in the case of
arithmetic circuits for the circuits and
learn the
parameters and so we have these two
types of uh a initial starting points
and circuits explore it naturally very
well by compilation The Logical
structure the local structure of the
functions in the case of Endor search
you can or you may not use it depending
on uh your methods
another uh maybe a
difference is that you the focus often
is on by valued varibles in the case of
arithmetic not focusing on multivalued
variables and representation is a table
of so that's the main difference or or
actually the point is that there is not
much difference and uh I will go and uh
talk from now on and I will I'll
describe the work that uh uses anything
algorithms with this so we are talking
about graphical models the starting
point these are examples very well
example just to uh to show you familiar
with this I assume uh protain folding
design or redesign is one of the focus
of our our work in recent years uh but I
will not have time to talk about it what
we want to start is from the formal
definition what are the graphical models
variables domains and the collection of
functions that represent some
probability distribution or some cost
function and they can be abstracted into
a graph Primal graph where each variable
is a node and you connect two nodes if
they appear in the same function and
this structure allow us to really uh it
captures conditional independencies that
exist in the probability distribution
and can be exploited very well uh and
what we want is to solve all these
problems here uh inference map some
inference weighted counting partition
function mixed inference the marginal
map when you have both summation and
maximization on top of the product and
also influence
diagram here is a picture
of and the difficulty of this problem is
getting harder as we go from top to
botom they all half and the philosophy
is to we cannot solve this problem
exactly most of the time but we can
explore the exact solution let's try to
have algorithms that with time we get
better and better Solutions and
eventually they have to get the exact
solution if can give them all the
resources uh and also let's try to
generate bounds whenever we stop we want
to have a bound on the exact solution
that we have so that's the the
picture
and this is a a an overview slide of the
approach that we have taken uh the
approach is the approach of listic
search so we do want to find a unifying
methods that is anytime as I said and
what I will argue is that euristic
search is a perfect framework for this
type of algorithms and what you see here
is a sech
space you see here a search space and
you need a aristic and I I will show
that we have the capability of compile
tics but take them to the next step and
use them within search and the search
will be over end of
search so let's start from uh to to see
what Endor search spaces are
fortical
models okay so you have here at the top
you have a graphical model and you can
immediately see that you can generate a
sudat Tre that captures conditional
independencies inate if you assign a
value to A and B these two subp are
independent so instead of laying all the
configuration all the assignments of
values our values to a variables in a
tree in a simple tree we can try to
explore the structure of the problem in
the search space we know that we can
explore the structure of problem in
algorithms such as variable elimination
bucket elimination this is immediated
but we those algorithms don't lend
themselves into anytime Behavior you can
solve the problem if the induced WID or
three WID is small otherwise you cannot
memory prohibited but search is more
flexible so we want to exploit the
structure and we can instead of thinking
about this three we can have this end or
tree in this end of or tree Once We
assign a and b a value the two these two
sub problems are decomposed into two sub
two sub trees and this is an end node
let's say let's solve this problem and
this problem independently given
the so you have a layer of uh what we we
depict here is the name of the variable
is we call it an or it has the values
and the the assignment node is an end
node it may root several problems that
all can be solved independently and this
is Guided by the pseudo tree of the
problem and here a solution is a path
here is a solution is a sub
tree there is another property that we
exploit that is just based on the graph
we know that often in search trees there
are several subt trees that are
identical it's often hard to recognize
them in advance but the graph allows us
to do that in this example uh we can see
that uh the sub problems below D and F
probably depends only on the value of D
and F so instead of having this end or
search tree we can recognize that
actually this is end or graph because
all these sub trees are the same and
this can be also discovered just by
looking at the graph and looking at
Notions such as context that I will
discuss immediately so to summarize the
main thing is that we are starting from
a graphical model and instead we can
consider the tree the the all search
tree but if we have the pseud tree and
we can always generate it the sud tree
is just a tree sping the graph that
don't have ARS
going between
branches then we can have the end or
tree it will have less Nots captures the
same probability the same set of
configurations
and we can also have the notion of
context that tells us that VAR that a
variable is independent given the
context from the rest of the problem for
instance the context of is just AE
because a is separated from the rest of
the problem so based on context we can
move trees to graphs we can do it for
the all trees and we can do it for the
end or tree and the number of nodes will
decrease and and you can see that here
in this structure that we call context
minimal and or graph we get the smallest
representation and this is just based on
the graph
and we can also characterize the graph
parameters that govern this
so the height of the sud Tre
characterize the size of the Endor tree
will be exponential in the the in the
induced WID or three width will
characterize the size of the context
minimal and or graph the path WID will
characterize the size of the or tree and
we can also generate those in that
amount of time so once we have this
realization we have the spectrum of
trees and we can solve any of the
queries that are we are interested in
over such or Define them over these
three and uh address the question of
algorithms to to answer those queries
please ask questions if you have any
questions during the talk so this was
just the graph but we have its knowledge
based its information we have to have
the parameters we sprinkle the
parameters on the ARs from the we can
from the tables and we can capture the
whole probability distribution uh the
the weights that we have on the tree the
product will be the product of the
configuration so this is just captures
the same probability distribution and
now we can try to uh H to explore the
search Tre or to Define on it the task
that we are interested in so for example
if we are interested in the probability
of evidence we can Define the notion of
a value the value will be the the
probability of evidence below each node
and we can uh recursively form leaves to
nod using a product for end nodes and
summation for all nodes at the same way
that it's done in arithmetic circuit we
can just propagate the information to
the RO and compute what we want in the
case of summation query in the case of
optimization query and we can do it on
the uh end or and we can do it on the
end or graph as well uh and in the
case what we will see that when we are
doing it in the case of Endor gra we
will need to cat some information for
the now it's depend I mean we can have
many sud trees and the questions of what
is a good the tree is uh was explored
this is just to illustrate that for this
problem got here you can have this sud
tree or this sud tree and this parameter
tree width and height are different in
them and it's not so clear which uh of
this end or search graphs that this
dictates would be uh
Superior uh if you you can catch
information you want the three-way to be
small if you decide of a linear memory
you want the height to be small and this
it's not possible to have both
parameters optimized on the same sud so
that was my introduction of end or
search classs I think many of you are
familiar with that
we also did use it for compilation we
explor the possibility of starting from
end or context minimal graph compile it
in the in the uh same nature that you do
with obds and we develop this notion of
end or multivalue decision diagram uh
and we're able to show here is a tree
here is the context minimal graph and we
can compact it and compact it to the
minimal and or multiv Val decision diagr
and uh the thinking is first of all
compilation obviously in some cases
would give you a lot because you put the
the circuit the the graph in memory but
we thought that this will help us
generate better listic as I will show
and uh um it can help but I will not
talk about this work uh anymore I will
focus as I said on how to now use the
end or search graphs for any time
alance so we want to use the search
Graph Search tree that we have as an
implicit structure that we explore not
an explicit structure and we explore it
if it's euristic search with the aid of
tics so in euristic search for each if
you are Computing the an optimization
you have you you are trying to have a
low bond for each node of the uh
a optimal solution or in the case of
summation the lower bound on the the
count and the question is how do you get
this uh
youris and it turns out that we can get
it also from from the graphical model by
compilation by doing these algorithms
that I mentioned the start like bucket
elimination which can be proceed as a
compilation
algorithm but we cannot do it exactly we
will do it approximately using a method
that is called mini bucket so what is
the idea you uh you have the the
functions and uh the the input function
and you are sending messages from one
variable by variable elimination you can
bound the size of the message by
partitioning and not sending a full
message on all the the all the functions
but just smaller functions and you can
control the size of the function by a
parameter like an i bound that says how
big would be the the message that you
are sending and the nice thing about
this method that it's guaranteed to give
you an upper bound lower bound it's a
perfect candidate for generating for new
istics so this is basically what we did
as a start and we also are able to
improve it by Notions such as cost
shifting between buckets these are
wellknown method in variational
community and also for summation uh a
summation queries we had the h power uh
algorithm and this leads to what we call
weight so here is this picture is the
again the high level view that I you you
may see again few times of the
methodology that we are
using you have the search tree and we
use the mini buet ristic to generate
before we start the the to solve the
problem we are compiling these functions
and they are standing there and can be
used when we are doing the search uh and
now that we have the two components that
we need the search space and the
euristic we can now tap into all the uh
literature of fistic search over the
last large last uh 50 years uh and uh
best ver best first search the type of
SE best SP death spur and cive search
and I will point on some of the
methods uh in the next slide but this is
a huge very uh valuable resources that
we simply took and imported it to our
domain here is so what I will do now I
will just uh show a little bit of our s
of our methods in a very high level
manner uh to really illuminate more of
what we've done this is just this is for
a solving map problem just to stress
that we are not rather than compile the
Endor tree we have this structure it
generate it implies an implicit and or
search graph and we are
exploring exploring it here in a dep
firsters Manner and you can see only
part of the uh problem is given and
again this is the same story that I said
before and what I want to talk about now
is on one to focus on one of these H
tasks that is the most difficult we
heard about it yesterday the marginal
map so our work started from map and
moved to Marginal map and summation
queries and to influence diagram and
marginal map is known to be the one of
the most difficult one queries because
you have here in this graph you have
variables that you want to optimize and
variables that you need to sum over
which dict
how the sud Tre uh it restrict the the
set of sudri that you can use and may uh
cause trees not to be trees as we saw in
the example uh yesterday and now this is
the end or graph it will also have the
maximization variables at the top
summation variables at the button but
this is again implicit we are not
generating this graph a priori we are
searching it to search only a small
portion of it with the aid of the
ristics that will also be generated for
this task and that's would be the
the so we now have the ingredient of uh
doing euristic search and a lot of the
work we have done uh since is to go and
uh think how we can generate anytime
algorithm namely provide an answer
immediately if necessary with bound but
continue and have better and better
Solutions and one of the ideas from
euristic search is to use ristic which
in this case we be able to provide upor
you know what would be the upper bound
to use we use ideas such as restarts
recursive search and combinations we
also use ideas of best first and deps
first search interleaving them one is
generating an upper bound one is
generating a lower bound and doing it in
a in a very in a variety of
sophisticated ways using look ahead
methods alternating and so on so all
this is easy to say fast that it this
requires significant work and a an
empirical evaluation to see what is
working the results that we show are
empirical we have a collection of
benchmarks the UI benchmarks and we run
the variety of algorithms that are
candidates uh that we develop on these
benchmarks and plot the results and the
main thing is to show how uh these are
just three instances
from of the benchmarks and these are
problems that it's hard to solve exactly
and you can see that the feature that we
would like to emphasiz is the fact that
which time the bounds you have an upper
bound and lower bound the same color is
the same algorithm that provide both uh
and we are trying to see which one is
doing best on which uh problem and we
can also play we have uh the the
strength of theistic is one of the
component this is an example of work
from weighted counting partition
function is a very difficult task
normally you cannot solve it exactly and
uh we develop on the same method ology
the and all search with the euristic now
for this task we developed
algorithm that will uh again provide us
with this anytime behavior and we
explore different versions trying to
come up with the best one or to see what
under what condition which algorithm is
better
so I will not go into more details on
this uh details of this work I will just
mentioned it in the last many years uh
we uh developed uh this class of
algorithms these are student thesis that
are focusing on aristic Sear but also
sampling for for to talk about Su
tasks and uh um I think some of
ComEd but never mind
uh that's fine
uh but I that's what I would like just
to share that these are several Theses
that we have the students some of them
are mentioned the beginning some of
them not we mentioned at end so if you
are interested you can go there and one
of the uh ways we evaluate uh the work
is using uh the UI competition so UI
competition uh started in
2006 uh we still we have also two
competitions since the 2014 and 2016
it's not here and 2022 that I will com
at the end and uh we were able to show
comparing with other people who
have in any kind manner we are able to
show that Al are pretty
strong and you can find the software uh
of allons that we are developing in uh
in my software
page uh and uh any questions uh you can
ask okay I I have 10 more minutes and
what I would like to do now is to focus
on to share with you some recent work
more recent work that we are doing now
that is focusing on S okay so search is
definitely uh uh valuable and you can
stop the search at any time but if you
want to solve summation queries sampling
is the natural approach and one of the
question is how to sample the search
space and exploit structure namely how
to sample the end or search space or
exploit structure uh and uh we have some
work two types of work that we uh
explored one is called end or end or
sampling that I'm not going to talk
about this is work
ofat and this is the more recent work
that we call abstraction sampling where
we are trying to uh to control to do uh
the the level of sampling and searching
that we are doing using the notion of
abstraction so overall the idea is uh
that if we are sampling as you know we
are normally if this is a search tree
normally it's common to do important
sampling to estimate theti function and
it will important sampling generate just
configuration and uh some them take the
average as an
estimate instead we would like to
consider sampling the subs the sub tree
of the problem not just a path but
sampling a sub tree so instead of
sampling this structure we can sample
this subtree to configuration in it and
provide an estimate or we can take it
further and estimate a larger subtree a
collection of them and they so this
picture gives us a transition on the
left left we are just doing only
sampling if you take it we take it all
the way we will do only search and we
will search once but we would like to
explore the potential of doing something
in between and improving
something now yeah what do these colors
represent maybe I'm missing yellow and
blue this is so I will disc maybe it
will be clear in in a minute so this is
this idea is coming from work by kot in
and Chen student Chen on estimating
search space
sizes cot introduced this sampling
approach on to estimate the size of a
back search tree if you try to solve the
constraint satisfaction problem and it
was taken later by aristic search people
to estimate the search space when you
are using your listic search Al in
advance because you don't know when you
start to solve problem what will be the
search space so we took it further and
this this is for summation query we took
it further to the idea of estimating the
partition function what is the idea the
idea is to subdivide the sege tree into
parts and to generate one sample from
each part so you are generating a tree
uh and um instead uh so we sub subdivide
this space into part enumerate over
parts and Sample within a part we call
each sampled sub tree a pole and
it resembles the notion of stratified
samples sampling in stratified sampling
we know the idea is to divide sample
from each STA and it can be proved that
it reduce the variance so REO proved
that if you are moving from regular
important sampling to satified import
sampling you can reduce the variance uh
by the number of stratas number of
elements stratas that you have and the
variance in between the stles so this
what we are doing is similar and I will
show you uh an example I think it will
be easiest an example but the idea is to
have an abstraction function or type
from their configuration in the cas to
some a subset of integers and then at
each layer in the search tree we divide
it into this abstract abstract St and we
sample from each one of them and this is
how we generate a sub
three so here is just an illustration
and it's an illustration on the or tree
so here is a a tree we can start by
generating the tree and we will use for
this example the value of a of a node as
the abstract state so if the we have
several nodes with zero they will be the
same abstract state so the first level
we we don't have we have only one note
in the second level we have b equals z
here and here this is the same state so
we stastically we choose one of them and
remove the
other so we will have at the end of this
level we will have just this two node
and we continue another uh abstraction
we stastically select one and that's the
end of our uh sampled subtree and we can
estimate it it's a sub tree we one thing
I forgot to really point is that as we
do that we change the weight associated
with each node because now it captures
more information at the end here we have
each configuration capture for path and
accordingly we do the this would be our
estimate here and we can do it many
times and we get this is the method uh
here is an illustration of how we uh we
extended to end or search tws so on the
left you have an end or search twe full
one and on the right is an example of a
sampled Tre that we create and we uh uh
take the average when we are doing the
computation it turn out to be a little
bit technically difficult to move uh
this idea to end or tree and to remain
in an unbiased State uh and we uh
developed a method that's that explore
the pudry in a dep first manner uh that
I will just illustrate here uh as you
can see at the end I have two nodes and
we remove one of them it's all done
stochastically with a proposal function
and this would be one
p and so here is the end of search tree
this is what we sampled and we do it
again in the G with the aid of a
proposal to uh decide which element will
be selected in
and you can see here theistic so
theistic that is again the weighted mini
bucket uh will be a component in our
proposal I will not get into how we are
doing it it works for any proposal but a
good one would help and that's the
method uh we can control the size of a
prob because we can control how many
abstract States we have which is n and
we have n variables so each P will be uh
bounded and we can prove that it's
unbiased and the Hope or the claim is
the the the variance is smaller if we
are doing it that way because a search
tree is just a collection of
configuration we have to show that doing
it in a controlled way in a tree is
better than just this configuration uh
doing
this within
tree so Val we the main question of
course is the abstraction function what
is it and we developed two types of
abstraction function one is based on the
context we know that if the context is
the same the two Sub sub trees are
identical and it will be exact to to
pull together all these uh states that
have the same context into one abstract
States but this would we would have too
many abstract States and we didn't do
anything but we can relax the content
select a subset of variables to
partition and we can also run rized and
select a randomized a has function over
the context these are two of the main
abstractions that we use that are based
on the context and then recently we
worked with urtic using the urtic as a
as a as a basis for
abstraction
and the main question is which
abstraction class is best what
granularity to use and so far we
experimented it with it on all these
benchmarks that we use and here I'm
showing just one graph on one problem a
recent one where we also illustrate the
difficulty of work with approximation
and anytime algorithm you can illustrate
the the power of this methods only on
hard problems and on hard problems you
don't know what is the exact answer so
what uh in this work what we did is we
ran this algorithm uh uh many many many
hours to get a Baseline that we propose
since it's a unbiased that it represent
sort of the exact answer and what we see
is that all these many uh variation of
this algorithm with
different fuctions with different grity
of the
obstructions operate as a function of
time and the one in this example and uh
that will is based on
theistic was this uh for not uniformly
but overall it was a show good
performance so I wanted to share this
this is the bottom the current status of
this end or search uh approach for
weighted counting uh
yeah we still have a lot of to explore
and uh I I promise to say something
about the UI competition we recently
revived the UI competition in
2022 and hope to continue this and uh
this is just a a illustration from the
web page you can look at the web page
the Abu we compare against the three
other approaches this is the results
this is the higher is better in this we
show performance at different time steps
and this is completely aggregation of
all these instances so abstraction
sampling in this case didn't appear
to inferior overall to some of these
methods uh in our experiments uh we
showed better performance in general but
one of the points is that all these uh
UI instances are easy because we have to
have the exact answer and we can it's
most of these problems are solving those
uh the problem exactly because it's
possible so but anyway my point here is
to Advocate and really invite people to
participate maybe this is something that
we can talk in the discussion just Ur to
me right now moving forward uh we are
going I mean we are learning we we have
some work on learning the abstraction
function and I think what uh drive us
forward is NE symbolic algorithm doing
some your network within our algorithms
and applying everything to
caal thank you I one more slide this one
so here is the main contributors and all
my students and my grook that was theed
is from
2019 focusing only on exact algorithm I
hope one day extend to approximations
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you so we have time for one quick
question
okay now you mentioned that when you do
sampling you lose the any time you don't
have the balce no okay you can compute
like confidence intervals or something
like okay so I these are there were two
slides or three slides that I commented
by mistake I think I went back and for I
wasn't sure how much time I we had and
this was on this P also there is also a
class of sampling algorithms that have
bounds way important sampling that we
used also in the new generation of the
marginal map approach algorithms we are
not solving the summation sub problem
exactly the first generation the
summation sub problem is chosen so that
it can be solved the problems that we
are illustrating of we exact but if we
cannot solve the summation sub problem
exact exactly we use simpling we use
weighted mini bucket important sampling
that provide upper and lower bound
probis stic bound so this is uh the main
way that we exploit sampling into this
uh search but obstruction sampling
doesn't have that uh cannot be
accompanied with bounds obstruction
sampling um because uh variety of things
but yes it's very important to really to
continue and have this and you can do
that some simp what happens is when you
take a weighted mini bucket important
sampling that is geared to provide good
bounds probalistic bounds and compare it
with regular importantance sing with any
function it appears to be inferior uh
but this but you don't know this a
priori posterior you see that these
other methods just give better
answers there is an additional work on
sampling sorry uh that I mentioned the
partition function all the work on
partition function providing up B is
based on simply I I just didn't talk
about it I mean you explore part of the
search you've sampled the rest
withing and get and lower bound and
there are a variety of tradeoffs
explored in those in that work and the
work that is sort of the superior one is
dynamic import sampling so if you want
to look at this work for partition
function Dynamic importance sampling
would be uh the key where you are trying
to decide whether to expand search or
sample in a dynamic fresh based on some
Statics okay so um just to keep good our
schu maybe we can take other questions
offline in the break
[Music]
so